fifteen thousand six hundred seventy
eight miles 116 days 35 States one very
dusty honda civic this is the road trip
that changed my life this road trip
started with one goal for me to land a
job as a local newspaper reporter but it
led me to much more it led me to a new
way of living this road trip way of
living is about having the guts to take
that first step it's about being open
and embracing the unexpected and it's
about taking the time to slow down and
reflect get on the road embrace the
detours slow down once in a while let me
tell you a little bit about life before
this road trip I left a good job in
network television to go to journalism
school in New York City by 2003 I
graduated with the dream of becoming a
newspaper reporter but newspaper jobs
were scarce in New York City and as hard
as I tried I had no idea how I was going
to get higher I felt paralyzed stuck in
my shoebox sized studio apartment in
Greenwich Village glued to my tiny ikea
couch I was going nowhere how was I
going to get a job I had never been paid
to write an article before had no
published clips no big New York City
newspaper was going to hire me I spent
days
let's be real weeks sitting on this
couch in this new york city apartment
the rising heat of this new york city
summer and finally i had had enough of
going nowhere it clicked what if instead
of reaching out to the big editors at
the big papers I reached out to editors
in smaller towns face-to-face at a small
town I could be have my own beat my own
byline I could have my own voice and so
I prepared to hit the road I took out a
loan i bought a car boom i was committed
yeah i bought a giant laminated map of
the u.s. i put little yellow dots at
each town that looked interesting I
would go south and then west I'd be on
the road for 18 days or so I thought
I'll never forget that feeling of
exhilaration as I drove across the
George Washington Bridge my new Honda
Civic packed to the windows I was
exhausted from days of preparation but
thrilled to finally be on the road
finally I was moving forward in life
we're taught to strategize to be
deliberate whether it's a job a
relationship a new home we really like
to know what to expect but sometimes the
best decisions we can make are based on
no data at all sometimes you need to
just push paralysis aside and just get
moving just go somewhere anywhere
sometimes you need to just get on the
road so that's what I did
I followed that map I went south
virginia north carolina south carolina
georgia i had my routine i was gaining
momentum my process was locked reach out
to those editors plan those
informational interviews show up in town
check into the motel 6 show up for the
interview and be ready for the
inevitable questions what are you doing
here why on earth would you leave New
York City and network television do you
really think this road trip is going to
get you hired I would work my charm as
best I could smile shake hands write
thank-you notes I kept on moving this
was my plan dot after dot on the map
finally I got to Tennessee and the
editor there suggested I reach out to
the sister paper in little rock but
Little Rock wasn't on my original map
I'd already made plans to go to
Louisiana Alabama I had to get out to
Missouri all within a matter of days
Little Rock would be an inconvenience
squeeze I'm not exactly sure why but I
ended up adding Little Rock to my agenda
a few days later I rolled into town it
was late at night I checked into the
first hotel I could find the next day I
was pleasantly surprised that the
reception I got at the Little Rock
newspaper the editor there was younger
than most I had met before he had
reddish hair a broad smile when he
showed me around this newsroom its lofty
ceilings and skylights there was an
energy to the place the buzz of
reporters working on deadlines i sat
down for an interview with that editor
he didn't ask the usual questions he
didn't think this road trip was such a
crazy idea in fact he was impressed with
it he was impressed with me he told me
there were no available positions at the
time but he would reach out if anything
opens up finally I felt like somebody
appreciated my efforts finally I felt
like I was making progress and this
detour was paying off sometimes the most
amazing destinations in life are not on
our original maps once the last time you
ditched your google calendar and made
time for something spontaneous let's
last time you put down your iPhone long
enough to have a conversation with a
stranger these opportunities for
unexpected interactions are everywhere
they happen all day dozens if not
hundreds of opportunities to make these
connections it's up to us to be open to
these opportunities meaningful ones when
they arise that's how it is on this road
trip way of life you get on the road and
you embrace the detours so after Little
Rock I kept moving west by then I was
sporting pretty serious left arm 10
and often i was driving for miles with
nothing but static on the radio i took
this time to conduct my own sort of
interview I took my time to ask myself
the tough questions I realized this road
trip was giving me the freedom to figure
out what I really wanted and I checked
in to realize that I actually did want
to live in a small town because I wanted
to have a big impact I wanted to make
sure that i worked with colleagues who
actually appreciated my experience this
is what I truly wanted and after many
more miles many more interviews I had
found a new focus in my final States
just the last few miles i got a call
back from that editor the one in Little
Rock who had been so impressed with me
and my road trip by then there were no
more questions in my mind yes I said as
he offered me a job is the new Little
Rock crime reporter that sounds perfect
let's face it even the most amazing road
trips can be tedious at times the roads
can start to look the same the motel 6
is I can assure you are all identical
but there's value in this monotony value
in these long stretches value and having
nothing else to focus on but what is
right in front of you some people find
these moments in long hikes or
meditation practice some people find
this time on a cross-country plane ride
without Wi-Fi the Guru's call it
mindfulness taking the time for the
present moment and your priorities and
for me the road is my mindful place my
chance to slow down and reflect on what
truly
makes me happy when it comes time for
your next big life decision remember
this road trip way of life maybe you're
feeling stuck paralyzed you don't know
what to do next what if you push the
risk assessments aside and just got out
there and just got moving maybe you're
already rolling full speed ahead towards
your final destination you know where
you need to go nothing will stand in
your way but if this is the case ask
yourself am I on autopilot am I missing
a chance for a meaningful detour and
every once in a while pause just long
enough to make sure that where you're
headed truly feels right in your gut
it's up to you to make this time for the
reflection for the mindfulness for
yourself get on the road embrace the
detours slow down once in a while
you